hi I'm Eddie Redmayne and I'm Katherine  Waterston it's time to get back in beast  mode you're welcome you're welcome  let's start with the nibblers because I  cannot even I can't even keep track of  them these little guys are prone to  shiny objects and endless mischievous  and you know how much I love boat  chuckles Pickett is the cutest and they  can pick locks and get you out of a jam  or into a jam they're also some beasts  in this new film that you guys haven't  seen yet yeah but you're gonna love it  meet the kelpie very hard to tame nasty  bite but quite long yeah new rides one  like a horse and it has seaweed doesn't  mean it's not weird at all and how can  you not love the ZOA  love is a bit of a strong word  [Music]  that was your beastly briefing we have  covered a few creatures but there are so  many more to catch up on in fantastic  beasts cars Grindelwald which is in  theaters this November